Prof: Then today we're
going to take our third look at
the history of life on this
planet,
and it's going to be about the
fossil record and the major
groups of life.
You remember,
the first look was major
transitions, and the issues
involved in them.
The second look was how life
shaped the planet and how the
planet shaped life;
so it was a description of the
geological theater in which
evolution has occurred.
And today we'll actually look
at the fossil record,
which has its own unique and
important messages.
So I'm going to again give you
another view of geological time.
This is something that's
important to build up in your
head.
It takes awhile.
The names are unfamiliar,
the depth of time is
astonishing.
But it's a very necessary
framework for understanding
evolution on this planet.
We'll talk about a few big
events, the major radiations,
the groups that are still
expanding,
the ones that are vanishing or
gone,
vanishing communities,
extraordinary extinct
creatures.
Then I'll mention stasis and
I'll also mention Cope's law.
So here is another way of
looking at geological time.
Last time I showed you the
24-hour clock.
This time I'm showing you a
series of blowups,
a three-panel blowup.
So here is the origin of the
planet.
Here is today, up here.
And the pre-Cambrian is in red.
So this is everything before
the major animal groups and
fossils with hard parts appear.
And, as you can see,
that's most of life.
Roughly speaking,
life begins here,
and becomes eukaryotic
somewhere around here,
and multi-cellular somewhere
around here,
and we start picking fossils up
at the beginning of the
Cambrian,
in any kind of numbers;
there were a few before then.
And then if we take everything
after the Cambrian--it's called
the Phanerozoic;
that's this column here--and we
blow that up,
and you can see it falls into
the Paleozoic,
the Mesozoic and the Cenozoic,
with all of these eras in it.
And some of these eras are
actually marked,
their endings are marked by
mass extinctions,
and the way that the geologists
could tell,
around the world,
looking at different rocks that
they were dealing with the same
rocks,
is that there are
characteristic fossils found in
them that disappeared all over
the world at a certain time.
And so, for example,
the disappearance--the
trilobites appear in the
Cambrian and they disappear at
the end of the Permian.
Any rock in the world that you
see that has a trilobite in it
is going to be in the Paleozoic.
The ammonites,
you'll see in a few minutes,
appear and disappear a number
of times, but they finally
disappear at the end of the
Cretaceous.
Any rock in it that's got a
complex ammonite in it is
Mesozoic.
So these geological eras are
actually,
in part, defined by fossils,
and the coordination of them
across the planet is done by
matching types of fossils.
In the late twentieth century
we had radiometric dating that
helped a great deal with this,
and that's gotten better and
better.
But the original layout was
done with fossils.
And if we then take everything
that's happened since the
end-Cretaceous mass extinction,
that's called the Cenozoic.
So this, the Mesozoic is more
or less the Age of Reptiles;
the Cenozoic is the Age of
Mammals;
and we blow the Cenozoic up,
this is what we get.
We get Paleocene,
Eocene, Oligocene,
Miocene, Pliocene,
Pleistocene.
And the last 10,000 years is
the Holocene;
that's since the glaciers
melted, that's the period we
call the Holocene.
And roughly speaking the world
restocks itself with
biodiversity in the Paleocene
and Eocene.
We have roughly modern levels
of biodiversity since the
Oligocene, in terms of mammal
families and things like that.
And most of the mammal orders
have their roots in the Eocene
and Paleocene;
as you'll see in a bit.
Now if we look at large-scale
events, one of the most
interesting is well when did
multi-cellular life really get
going?
And for that the tiny fossils
that are preserved in phosphate
beds in China are absolutely
astonishing.
These things have been
discovered within the last ten
years.
They come from a number of
places in China,
but this spot,
Chengjiang, in Yunnan Province,
is--I think it's on Yunnan;
it might be just on the border
with another province there;
no province lines in the
map--are certainly some of the
earliest and most intriguing.
So the Cambrian starts at about
550.
So this is 20 million years
before the Cambrian;
we're in the Vendian,
we're in the late-Proterozic
Era.
And a lake, or an inlet,
dried up and the salts in it
crystallized and they perfectly
preserved the algae that were in
it.
So these are micrographs of
microfossils showing
multi-cellular algae,
and in some of them you can
even see the spindles in the
mitotic divisions.
In formations in China of the
same age, there are
multi-cellular,
bilateral animals.
These look like early-stage
cell divisions of Crustacea.
So this is again 20 million
years before the Cambrian,
and the implication that there
might be a Crustacean 20 million
years before the Cambrian is a
very interesting one,
as you'll see in a minute.
So our molecular phylogenies
suggest,
looking not at the fossils but
at the molecules,
that the eukaryotic
radiation--so that's before
multi-cellularity;
this is just the eukaryotic
cells making Protista--that was
underway about a billion years
ago.
These microfossils support the
idea that many groups may have
diverged before the Cambrian,
but we have no trace of them in
the fossils.
We just have this marker;
we have these Crustacean-like
embryos.
Now if that's really true,
then the first fossils of large
animals,
animals that you could see with
the naked eye,
that had hard body parts,
that had endoskeletons or
exoskeletons,
these things crop up in the
Cambrian,
and they may simply then be
recording the fact that formerly
soft-bodied things started to
acquire skeletons.
So the groups existed before
then, they just couldn't be
fossilized, and that that may
very well have been because of
co-evolution with predators.
So that's the picture that
seems to be emerging.
I just want to remind you that
the Tree of Life has these three
big groups in it,
and we're now going to blow up
this part of it.
Here we are.
The Chinese microfossils look
like they're right about here,
and they are at 570 million
years ago.
And if we just walk out around
the Tree of Life,
and say, "Oh,
anything that has that branch
length from what we think is the
origin,
was probably there at the same
time,
even though we don't have a
fossil of it."
That's the implication of the
molecular phylogeny;
it's that everything else
that's about that far out from
the common ancestor was probably
there at the time.
That means that all these other
branches were there too.
Now most of these other things
are single-celled organisms,
and we wouldn't expect them to
leave fossils.
Okay?
I mean, we've got stuff like
slime molds and amoebas and
euglenas, the ancestors
of--let's see,
where is malaria and stuff like
that?
We've got all kinds of algae
out here.
Those things were probably all
there.
We just don't have fossils of
them.
And that's why it's really
important to be able to deal
with both the molecular
phylogenies and the fossils,
because they complement each
other and they allow a kind of
inference that's not available
from either alone.
Now, what happens in the
Cambrian?
That's when we really start-
when the fossil record really
gets going.
The idea that there was an
explosion of biodiversity in the
Cambrian seems to be well
supported by the fossils.
Okay?
This is the number of orders
that can be observed,
of animal groups.
So these are fairly large
clades of marine invertebrates
that start--
and some, by the way,
by the end of the Cambrian,
we start picking up vertebrates
as well--
and they start getting added on
at a pretty high rate.
And the interesting thing is no
major body plans appear in the
fossil record,
in animals, after that.
They do in the plants,
but in the animals it's as
though there's one burst of
diversity,
550 million years ago,
and then all the major body
plans get frozen,
and we don't get new kinds of
animals after that.
That's kind of a puzzling and
not completely solved problem.
Why was it that way?
Now let's take a look at one of
these communities.
They contain some organisms
that are profoundly weird.
By the way, they weren't very
big.
The giant among them,
the sperm whale of the Cambrian
seas was this guy,
up here.
Okay?
That's Anomalocaris,
and that is an arthropod
predator,
arthropod-like predator,
and it's got some funny sort of
quasi-tentacle antennae,
and a mouth right here,
and it swims around,
and it's the biggest,
nastiest thing in the ocean,
and it's about this big.
So if you are skin-diving in a
Cambrian sea,
you don't need to worry about
white sharks.
You are actually the biggest,
meanest thing around.
Okay?
And that's an interesting
observation.
Again and again,
in fossil history,
things start small and get big.
Things start small and have
short generation times and short
lives, and get to be big and
have long generation times and
long lives.
And I don't mean by that that
the small things are replaced by
the big things;
the big things add onto them.
It's like a community would be
dominated initially by small
things, and they would continue
to be there, but big things
would evolve.
So this is that process
starting to happen.
There are a few things that
were running around,
in these oceans,
that we don't have anymore.
There are trilobites here,
of course.
There is this profoundly
puzzling creature.
Okay?
And we're going to--that's
Opabinia--we're going to take a
good look at it,
in a few minutes.
That's one of the favorite
animals of Derek Briggs,
who's now the director of the
Peabody Museum.
Derek, by the way,
has great BBC cartoons of the
way these things swam and moved.
He's done the functional
morphology of the Cambrian
community.
So if you're interested in
that, maybe you could talk Derek
into having a showing.
So that is something that's not
around anymore.
But something like this is.
That's a priapulid worm,
and there are still priapulid
worms that look pretty much like
that.
So that thing is now a living
fossil.
And here's an Onychophoran,
and Onychophorans that look
just like that are running
around the Australian
rainforests now;
instead of living on reefs,
they're running around the
rainforest, but they look pretty
much like that.
Okay?
So the things that we get in
the Cambrian are at least three
of the mollusk classes.
So these are the chitons,
these are the snails,
and these are the squids,
octopuses and ammonites.
We get the polychaetes,
which are the biggest group of
the annelids--the ones that are
most familiar to you are
probably earthworms;
those are oligochaetes.
But the polychaetes--I think
there are 43 families of
polychaetes.
They're a very dominant group
in the ocean,
and have been for 550 million
years.
We start getting arthropods;
so we get the trilobites.
The chelicerates are the
horseshoe crabs and the spiders
and their relatives,
and we start picking up some
Crustacea.
We get the brachiopods,
the lampshells,
which are still around.
If you go diving on a reef in
Malaysia, you can see
brachiopods.
There are deep-water
brachiopods around the world,
but they've mostly been in
retreat for a long time.
And we get echinoderms,
and the fact that we get
echinoderms is interesting
because they're the sister group
of the chordates,
and that implies that the
chordates had diverged from the
echinoderms,
at that point,
and they just weren't
fossilizing.
And we know,
from the first fossils that we
can get of things like
Amphioxus,
that if you have a tiny,
little, one-inch long,
translucent,
tadpole-like,
fish-like chordate,
that's the ancestor of the
vertebrates,
it's probably not going to
fossilize.
So our best evidence that that
divergence had occurred is the
existence of the echinoderms.
And by the way,
the echinoderms went through an
explosive radiation.
They made many classes.
The different classes of the
echinoderms now are things like
the asteroids,
which are the starfish;
the holothuroids,
which are the sea cucumbers,
and so forth.
There are, I think,
six or seven classes currently
of echinoderms;
but back in the Cambrian there
were about twenty-five or
thirty.
Most of them have now gone
extinct.
And some of those things that
you saw in that earlier picture
were extinct classes of
echinoderms.
Okay, so for the animals
there's this explosion 550 to
500 million years ago in the
Cambrian.
It's very different for the
plants.
The plants had a much steadier,
more measured evolution of
diversity.
Okay?
The major groups of plants
arrive later because plants got
onto land later.
Most of the animal groups,
all the animal groups
originated in the ocean,
but much of plant diversity
originated on land;
so they had to get onto land.
The mosses and the ferns appear
in the fossil record in the
Devonian, about 400 million
years ago.
The gymnosperms,
which is pines and firs and
their relatives,
they actually are
350-million-years-old.
So they appear in the early
Carboniferous,
and they undergo continuing
evolution up to the present day.
So they keep getting-
diversifying and becoming more
sophisticated.
But there are recognizable
gymnosperms 350 million years
ago.
And when the flowering plants
evolve depends on whether you're
looking at molecules or fossils.
The molecules suggest that it
might be as old as
Carboniferous-Permian-Triassic;
that is, 200 to 300 million
years ago.
Some people don't believe that.
The really solid evidence,
of course, is the fossil,
at a certain age,
and that's in the
late-Cretaceous.
So you can see angiosperms that
are 75-million-years-old in the
fossil record.
This is what the first plant on
land might have looked like,
and the first plant on land
might actually have been a
liverwort.
So this is a thalloid liverwort.
And when you look at it,
it looks a fair amount like
algae that we are familiar with
and that we see in the
intertidal zone.
It doesn't really look that
different in its structure from
a marine alga,
but it is adapted for living on
land.
And to get onto land this is
what you need.
If you're an animal,
you're going to have to come up
with an impermeable skin.
If you want to locomote on
land, you'll need limbs,
and for that you'll need
shoulder and hip supports.
And if you want to reproduce on
land,
rather than in the water--which
is,
of course, what many of the
amphibians have continued to
do--
then you'll need an egg that
won't dry out.
So you need a shell and an
amnion, and this basically is
something that happened between
the amphibians,
and then everything that came
later in the tetrapods.
If you're a plant,
you need an impermeable leaf.
That means you need to invent
the biochemistry and the
developmental biology to make a
waxy cuticle.
You need a means of gas
exchange.
So you're going to have to
invent all of the neat stuff
about stomata and stomatal
regulation of carbon dioxide
coming in and oxygen going out.
And you'll need to have roots,
resistant spores;
eventually you'll need seeds.
So there's really quite a bit
of stuff to evolve,
when you come onto land.
This is a major event.
It was complicated and it took
some time.
If we look at the vertebrates
coming onto land,
here are some late-Devonian
lobe-fin fish.
So the group that seems to have
spawned the tetrapods is related
to the Coelacanths,
the lobe-fin fishes.
I'll show you a picture of
Eustenopteron and Ichthyostega
in a moment.
And these things start--this
creature, Eustenopteron,
is actually a pelagic fish.
It's not really crawling around
in the drying up lagoon;
it appears to be swimming in
open water.
But, as you'll see in a minute,
it has really pretty good
beginnings of the tetrapod limb.
So it looks like some of the
structural elements in the
skeleton,
that were needed for things to
come on land,
probably developed for other
reasons,
in another environment,
as an exaptation,
something that happened for
other reasons earlier in
evolution,
and that could then be co-opted
and used to get onto land.
And these are some of the
relatives.
Okay?
So you can see Coelacanths in
the fossil record at 360 million
years, and you can see them from
a submersible off Madagascar
today.
They're a nice living fossil.
Here's Eustenopteron.
The skeletons are recovered
from Miguasha in Quebec;
385-million-years-old.
It was a pelagic fish,
and you can see that it already
is getting, in its hind limbs,
many of the identifiable
elements of a vertebrate limb.
So this is a blowup of the
pectoral of Eustenopteron.
It appears to have a humerus.
This is Ichthyostega.
This thing is a transition form
between fish and amphibia.
It's late-Devonian;
it's 20 million years later.
These usually come from eastern
Greenland;
that's where the fossil
deposits are.
And this guy already has most
of the elements of the
vertebrate limb.
So this developed in a swimming
environment.
This guy arguably was crawling
around in shallow water,
but he can't support himself as
an adult.
That shoulder girdle and the
hip girdle are not strong enough
for that animal to actually walk
on land, if it's an adult.
The larvae could.
So perhaps the first stage of
coming onto land was the kids
went exploring,
and then they went back in the
water and grew up to be adults.
The parents couldn't go into
the new habitat because they
didn't have limbs that were
strong enough to support them.
I think that's kind of a cool
idea.
So it might have been that,
just like with computers,
the young were showing the old
which way was up.
If we look at the plant
radiation,
there's a whole series of
acquisitions of major elements
of what it means to be a plant,
and they occur at a pretty
steady pace between about 450
and 75 million years ago.
So chlorophyll B is quite old.
I would guess that chlorophyll
B is on the order of maybe 1 to
1.5 billion years old.
You get plant cell structure
probably at the level of about a
billion years.
You get alternation of
generations, haploid/diploid
generations, coming in pretty
early.
Then you have,
as you move out of the mosses,
and move towards the club
mosses, you can see that the
water delivery system,
of plants, starts to develop.
So they're developing roots and
they're developing all of the
plumbing that will allow water
to move and bring nutrients from
the roots up into a growing
structure.
Wood starts to develop right
about in here,
and by the time you get up into
the Equisitifolia and the
precursors to the gymnosperms,
you're getting pretty well
developed xylem;
so you're getting phloem,
complex xylem,
and a pretty good delivery
system.
Then the seeds evolved with the
gymnosperms;
gymnosperm means naked seed.
And this is the radiation here
of the gymnosperms.
The Pinales would be the pine
trees, and firs,
and all of that.
And the Gingkoes,
of course, are the familiar
Gingko trees;
there's one down here at the
corner of the Peabody Museum.
And that makes a clade.
And that's where seeds were
invented.
Then as we go up further,
we get into pollen grains that
have a distal aperture,
and then finally we get to the
flowering plants.
And at the base of the
angiosperms,
down here, there are some
wonderful and weird plants,
and the only one that I'd
really like to mention now,
time permitting,
is Welwitschia,
which is the Gnetales.
And Welwitschia is a plant that
basically is a root with two
leaves, and the two leaves can
grow to be up to 100 or 200 feet
long.
It lives in the sand dunes of
Namibia,
and because sand drifts and
makes dunes that grow,
Welwitschia can keep growing to
keep its leaves on top of the
dunes.
And so some Welwitschias are
actually 100 or 200 feet high;
it's just that they're all
below ground and they just have
these big leaves that come out
the top.
So there are wonderful things
that are represented in the
plant radiation.
Okay, so the theme of that
basically--let me just go back
and reinforce these two points.
Some of the stuff that you need
to get on land was developed
earlier in the water,
for other reasons,
and then was co-opted to get
you on land,
and that's what probably
happened with the vertebrate
limb.
The plants developed much of
their diversity after they had
gotten onto land.
And you can see that they are
adding things like vascular
canals and water delivery
systems and things like that--
wood--at a fairly steady pace,
as you go up through a period
between about 450 and 75 million
years ago.
If we then look at large
patterns in the history of life,
to see what kinds of messages
the fossils give us,
this is one of the classical
ones.
This is how many different
families of ammonites there
were.
Okay?
And you can think of each of
these radiations,
that are presented as kind of a
leaf with grey coloring around
it,
as being roughly at the level
of an order.
So an order of mammals would
be--to make it familiar to
you--would be something like the
ungulates.
An order of birds would be
something like the albatrosses
and their relatives.
Fairly big groups with a lot of
species in them.
And within each of these groups
you can see that there are lots
of families.
Now look what happens to them.
At the end of the--they start
to radiate,
back in the Devonian--at the
end of the Devonian there's a
mass extinction,
lots of them get cut off,
two lineages come through.
This lineage radiates,
makes a whole lot of different
species and families of
ammonites.
At the end of the Permian,
they all go extinct.
This line here manages to get
two of them through--two
lineages, maybe three--through
the Permian mass extinction.
One of them goes out in the
Triassic;
the other radiates.
At the end of the Triassic
there's a mass extinction.
Almost all the ammonites
disappear again.
One or two lineages get
through, into the Jurassic,
and at the end of the
Cretaceous these two surviving
branches both go extinct.
So people looked at that,
and what they saw was this
continuing extinction,
and then re-radiation,
and extinction,
and re-radiation,
and they asked themselves,
"Can the world hold only
so many kinds of ammonites?
Does it kind of fill up,
and then when it's wiped clean,
does that create a space for
the others to re-radiate?"
Well the pattern is consistent
with that interpretation.
Consistency is a very weak
logical criterion;
but it's evocative.
So I leave it at that.
Now that consistency comment's
going to apply to this as well.
So this is the mammal radiation.
Okay?
And when you look at it,
the first thing you notice is
oh, mammals started to radiate
back in the Triassic.
If we were back in the Triassic
we might not have called them
mammals yet,
but they have already split off
from other ancestors,
and it looks like things like
the Monotremes have their roots
at about that level in time.
So we're looking back about 200
million years.
During the whole time that
dinosaurs were the dominant
large creatures on the planet,
and the most diverse tetrapods,
the mammals continued to
radiate.
There were multituberculates,
there were triconodonts;
there were all sorts of things,
back there.
They tended to be rather small,
but they were perking along.
Then there's the end-Cretaceous
extinction.
Everything bigger than five
kilos that lives on land gets
wiped out, and the mammals then
radiate.
Well that is consistent with
the idea that the extinction of
the dinosaurs was a necessary
pre-condition for the radiation
of the mammals.
And it looks like a reiteration
of the pattern we saw with the
ammonites: clean the planet out
and make space,
and then they can evolve again.
So this is really kind of a
tetrapod recapitulation of what
we saw with the ammonites.
But, as I said,
consistency is a weak logical
criterion, and the problem is
we're dealing with one planet,
and we don't have replicates.
>
It would be nice if we could
replicate this experiment a
hundred times and see that every
time the dinosaurs went extinct,
the mammals radiated.
Okay?
We have a sample size of one.
So it's a very interesting
pattern.
It might very well be true.
It sounds plausible,
and you can't demonstrate it
experimentally.
So what are the groups that are
still radiating?
If we just look around the
planet right now,
what do we see?
Well the beetles are still
going like gangbusters.
We don't actually know how many
beetles there are.
The number of beetles that have
been named is I think about
350,000.
The number of beetle species
that might exist could be on the
order of 5,000,000.
When J.B.S. Haldane,
who was an atheist Communist,
was having dinner with the wife
of the Archbishop of Canterbury,
she asked him,
"Mr. Haldane,
what do you conclude about the
nature of the creator from your
study of biology?"
And he turned to her and said,
"Madame,
an inordinate fondness of
beetles."
>
So there are a lot of beetles,
and they're still radiating.
The Diptera,
the flies and the mosquitoes,
are a young group,
and they are still producing
new species.
Among the mammals,
it's the bats that are probably
the most impressive producers of
biodiversity,
along with the rodents.
And the place where the bats
and the rodents are doing the
most of this is in South
America.
So if you really are a
mammalogist,
and you want to study recent
evolution and see things that
are still in the process of
speciating,
South America is certainly one
good place,
and the groups to look at are
bats and rodents.
In the flowering plants,
there is really impressive
biodiversity in the composites,
the orchids and the grasses.
There are about 12,000 species
of orchids I think.
And I have forgotten--Jeremy,
do you know the figures for the
grasses?
Teaching Assistant:  Yes.
I think there's somewhere
around 15,000.
Prof: 15,000 species of
grasses and composites.
Teaching Assistant:
There's around 30,000.
Prof: There are about
30,000, and they probably don't
even call them composites
anymore.
Teaching Assistant:  No.
Prof: What are they
called?
Teaching Assistant:
Asteraceae.
Prof: They're called
Okay, see, the phylogeneticists
are busy, they're on their game,
they're naming stuff.
Now that's---those are the
clades that are currently
filling the world with life.
What about the stuff that's
been wiped out?
Well all of those exotic things
in the Burgess Shale,
they're gone forever,
and they've been gone for
hundreds of millions of years.
The trilobites,
the ammonites,
the dinosaurs,
those are all gone.
There was a wonderful group
called the glossopterids.
They were Jurassic tongue-ferns;
they were ferns that looked
tongue-like.
There's a great story about how
when South America got connected
to North America,
at the Isthmus of Panama,
about 10 million years ago,
a bunch of tough,
North American hoodlums
migrated south,
over the Isthmus,
and ate up everything in South
America.
They were called things like
pumas and wolves and stuff like
that, and they ate up the South
American notoungulates.
There were a few things that
came north;
possums, armadillos came north,
but most of it was a movement
south.
And so there was a complex
Miocene and Pliocene fossil
fauna in South America that's
vanished forever.
In the last 10,000 years,
mostly on islands in the
Pacific, 25 to 35% of the
world's birds have gone extinct.
And outside of Africa,
most of the Pleistocene
megafauna is gone.
If you want to see what the
Pleistocene looked like,
go to a national park in
Africa, because that's what
North America looked like 10,000
years ago,
when we had 300,400-pound
beavers;
and there was a North American
lion that was bigger than an
African lion;
and of course the mammoths and
the wooly rhinos and all of
those things.
So we are actually missing a
lot of this stuff.
And, on the one hand,
none of us probably ever woke
up in the middle of the night,
in a cold sweat,
worrying about the fact that
the dinosaurs were extinct and
we couldn't see them anymore.
And some ornithologists,
who know about the recent
history of extinction in the
world's birds,
probably do occasionally wake
up in a cold sweat at two
o'clock in the morning and worry
that they were gone.
But most of this stuff,
we regard that as oh,
it's in the drawers of the
Peabody Museum;
it's old, dusty fossils.
But basically what we're
talking about here is vanished
worlds;
vanished complete communities,
vanished profligate,
extravagant radiations that
produced life,
that filled up the planet,
and then disappeared.
And 99% of it's gone;
we see a very small fraction
that remains.
And that's actually just a fact
of life.
Okay?
It doesn't actually necessarily
call for an emotional response,
other than the observation that
hey, that's what happens.
Now let's go back to one of
those places.
This is a vanished community,
this is the Burgess Shale,
and about 500 million years
ago--the Burgess Shale is about
505 million years old,
so it's sort of late-Cambrian.
At that point--this is the
North American craton here;
so looking at its western edge,
it's eastern edge would be
Quebec, and then this would be
northern Canada,
up here.
This is the western edge.
At that point it's slightly
south of the equator.
It's not connected to South
America or to Asia,
at that point.
This is where it is today.
You're up at about 10,000 feet;
you're about two kilometers
above sea level;
maybe 8000 feet.
This is a geologist,
and this is a fossil from the
Burgess Shale.
That one happens to look like a
trilobite.
Okay?
And this is the shale here.
So at this site,
505 million years ago,
on the western edge of the
continent,
there was a shallow water
community that was living on the
edge of a cliff,
and occasionally the cliff
would fall down,
the sediment on the cliff would
fall down,
and it would bury things;
and that's what the shale
consists of.
You're looking basically at a
landslide that buried a lot of
stuff.
And these are the kinds of
things that it buried.
So here is our priapulid.
Here is Opabinia.
Here is Anomolocaris;
it looks like a huge looming
predator in that shot;
but remember,
the biggest thing in the ocean
was that big,
and that's this guy right here.
Here's one cruising in the
background.
And these are some of the
creatures that you can pull out
of that shale.
This is one of the most
abundant.
This is Marella.
This is a primitive arthropod.
Now remember the HOX genes,
remember how to turn an
onychophoran into a fly?
Well this is an intermediate
step.
Basically you take a worm and
you start specifying that the
forward segments are going to
form a head.
So you get cephalization.
You can see that it's putting
out gills and legs on most of
its segments--
but it's kind of stopping to do
that on its back segments--
and it's developed a hard
exoskeleton.
So this is steps on the way to
becoming an arthropod.
And we actually don't know
whether this thing is the
ancestor of Crustaceans or of
the chelicerates or the
trilobites.
It's just an intermediate form
between a worm and an arthropod.
This thing is just totally
bizarre.
This is Opabinia.
Okay?
And when it was first
reconstructed,
it resulted in hilarity;
nobody could believe it.
And the thing that really gets
people about it is that it has
five eyes,
and it's got this proboscis
that's got kind of a grasping
organ out on the end of it.
So it looks sort of like a
cross between a spider and a
vacuum cleaner.
It's probably about this big.
Okay?
It's about one or two inches
long.
And people just couldn't figure
out where Opabinia fits.
So Derek Briggs has made the
study of Opabinia one of his
projects;
he knows a lot about it.
And it appears to be related to
Crustacea.
But again you can see that it
looks like it's intermediate
between a worm and something
else.
So it's probably some kind of
intermediate form,
prior to the arthropods.
Now before I go on to stasis
and Cope's rule,
I just want to comment a little
bit on what it means that entire
communities have completely
vanished.
It really places a very
relative view on the current
world.
When the Atlantic was
opening--and the Connecticut
River Valley might have been the
Atlantic, or it could've been a
river valley on a continent;
it was a rift valley at that
time--there were a series of
rift valley lakes that stretched
across eastern North America.
They run basically from
Pennsylvania up to about
Vermont.
And they opened and closed,
and opened and closed several
times.
Every time one of those lakes
opened,
the fish in them went through a
big adaptive radiation,
like the ammonites did,
and then the lake closed and
all the fish died off,
and then it opened up again and
another radiation of fish went
on in it,
and it closed up;
and this happened again and
again and again,
both spatially and temporally,
across the eastern United
States, about 200 million years
ago.
We're currently in the middle
of a big anthropogenic
extinction crisis,
but it appears like this isn't
something that the planet hasn't
experienced before.
Geological processes have
caused many extinctions of
entire communities,
wiped them completely off the
face of the earth,
and life has re-generated new
ones again and again and again
and again.
So that was one of the messages
I'm hoping that you're getting
from the fossil record.
Now what about stasis?
What about the fact that the
Coelacanth that you catch off
the Comoro Islands today,
looks almost exactly like the
Coelacanth that's in the fossil
record from 360 million years
ago?
What about the fact that the
Onychophorans that you collect
in Australia today are
practically indistinguishable
from the ones that you see in
the Burgess Shale 505 million
years ago?
Why is there stasis?
And I mention this because if
you were to write down a list of
the big intellectual problems
that are posed by fossils,
this is certainly going to be
on everybody's list.
There are others,
but this is going to be a
prominent one.
And this is something that was
called to the attention of the
world's scientific community,
primarily by Steve Gould.
This is one of the take-home
messages of his life.
So stasis basically describes a
long period with no
morphological change.
There's no apparent response to
selection.
Evolution doesn't appear to be
going on.
And it is puzzling,
because we know that every
nucleotide sequence undergoes
mutations.
There is no way that you can
stop the production of genetic
diversity in these organisms.
Okay?
So for 350 million years
Coelacanths don't change,
but probably every nucleotide
in their genome has mutated,
over that period of time.
So there's been opportunity for
change, but they have not
changed.
The examples of this include
club mosses and liverworts,
lungfish, Coelacanths,
the priapulids and phoronids.
You saw the priapulids--I
pointed them out in the
Cambrian- in the Burgess Shale
shot--
tuataras currently still
existing on an island off New
Zealand,
and onychophorans;
there are others.
So here are a couple of
onychophorans.
They're kind of intermediate
between annelids and arthropods;
velvet worms.
And here are two possible
explanations for stasis.
There may very well be others,
but I want you to have at least
these two general ones in your
toolkit.
And one is basically a
selectionist explanation for
stasis.
It says that most of the things
that we're talking about have
some method where either a larva
or a seed can find the
environment in which the adult
will do well.
And so there is a selection of
an environment,
early in life,
and that actually then selects
the selection pressures that
will operate on the adults.
We see the adults,
we don't see the larvae.
Basically the larvae have been
wandering around the planet,
searching out the environment
in which the adults will grow
up,
for hundreds of millions of
years;
and we know that marine larvae
are extremely good at this.
The Coelacanths,
we know that they're deep-sea
creatures;
they live down at about 600 to
1000 feet.
That's a fairly stable
environment.
The club mosses,
that's a little harder to see
how this would work.
But at any rate,
this is one option.
Okay?
So this is one of our
alternative hypotheses.
The reason things stay the same
is that young life history
stages find the environment in
which adult selection will take
place,
and adult selection is
stabilizing.
Intermediate values are
selected for.
Things don't change.
On the other hand,
there's a contrasting
hypothesis, which is an
internalist explanation.
Basically it is that tradeoffs
are creating the stabilizing
selection--
that's one possibility--so that
instead of having an ecological
explanation for why there's a
long period of stabilizing
selection,
we have an internal
physiological or developmental
explanation of why selection has
been stabilizing.
But there's another part,
another option in the
internalist explanation,
and that is that early on,
both in evolution and early on
in development,
key traits get fixed;
key things get set up.
The development of the eye
depends upon the relationship of
two tissue layers,
so that there will always ever
thereafter be nerves and blood
vessels in front of the retina.
Okay?
So if those things are laid
down early, both in evolution
and then in development,
occur early in development,
there's kind of an embedding.
That means things have been in
place that can't be changed
without destroying normal
development.
Now there are arguments for and
against all of these things.
You can find early
developmental traits that have
undergone a lot of evolution
without destroying the adult
form.
So there are some real issues
with trying to understand the
mechanics of how this would
work;
and we don't know yet.
Okay?
I'm just giving you a few ideas
that bear on the issue.
The other major take-home
message is--that I've already
signaled as Cope's Law.
And again, there are two
options here.
One is that the reason that we
see bigger things is that
there's just a neutral
evolution.
Adaptive radiations have been
creating little things and big
things.
But there was more room on the
upper end than there was on the
lower end;
therefore even though it's been
random, we see an accumulation
of larger things,
just because the upper limits
are far away.
Okay?
The lower limit on body size is
always nearby;
it's one cell,
you don't get smaller than one
cell.
But the upper limit appears to
be redwood trees and blue
whales, and at least at the
outset that's pretty far away.
That's up at about 100 meters,
for redwood trees,
and about 30 meters for blue
whales.
So that's one possibility.
The other is that the reason
that things got bigger is
co-evolutionary.
Co-evolution is shaping prey to
escape and predators to kill,
and prey can escape predators
by getting too big to eat,
and predators can kill big prey
by getting bigger than they are.
So this would be an adaptive
life history hypothesis,
saying that Cope's law results
from a co-evolutionary arms race
between predator and prey.
And we don't really yet have a
powerful method for
disentangling these two effects.
And I think if you look at
their logic, you can see that
they're not mutually exclusive;
they can both be going on at
the same time.
Okay, so what does the fossil
record tell us?
It shows us a lot of stuff that
we couldn't see at shorter time
scales.
We see a lot more detail in the
recent than in the distant past.
It looks like mass extinctions
may open up ecological space,
for the radiation of surviving
groups.
So it may be that you need an
extinction before you can have a
big radiation.
Most things start small and get
big.
And there's a lot of stuff
that's not on the planet at all
anymore;
there are no surviving
descendants.
So the fossil record has a
take-home point,
that's actually a puzzle that
can be attacked experimentally,
in part by people doing
evolutionary developmental
biology and phylogenetics,
and that is,
why is there stasis?
It's common,
and we don't have an
explanation for it.